this is the second generation of the
Peugeot 3008 the designers really went
to town and have basically invented an
entirely new vehicle this is what the
first edition looked like when it was
born in 2009 a typical family van it has
now morphed into a compact SUV
[Music]
mrs. Naumann we're not testing a regular
three thousand eight but the souped-up
sporty version the GT gets here the
2-liter diesel generates 133 kilowatts
in attains maximum torque of 400 Newton
meters in just 2,000 RPM 0-200 takes 8.9
seconds top speed is 211 kilometers an
hour
that's the Sun the GT has a special
sport drive mode button says eNOS
it's like tickling Alliance tummy till
it roars and bounds off in a flash the
GT is more dynamic than you might expect
in sport drive mode the gear shifts at
higher rpms and the engine sounds throat
here Wow what Manhattan motor sounds I'm
in the home
when office the suspension is good
though the center of gravity is quite
high it is really fun to take the curves
for them for fun
[Music]
the new 3008 certainly looks the part of
a contemporary SUV it's got under ride
protection plastic trim framing the
wheel wells and the high body the
trapezoid exhaust looks snazzy and
sporty awesome what is striking in the
interior is the small steering wheel
with a GT logo here and it's flattened
top and bottom it's meant to make a very
sporty impression says eNOS but it looks
too small in the context of a compact
SUV the materials and workmanship are
excellent all the services feel good and
enhance the futuristic feel
[Music]
the design of the controls for the
display and other functions are
eye-catching the gearbox is a 6-speed
automatic
[Music]
that's who Joe has entirely done away
with analog displays in the new 3008
says eNOS all versions have the new I
cockpit first you have to start the
motor while graphics are razor sharp
ones are perfect you can adjust them
with this little wheel choosing what the
dial should show and how another the -
Dunamis
put off with the pre-show 3008 is
designed to please all the senses not
just the hands and the eyes but the nose
as well among the apps is a fragrance
dispenser to make the cabin smell good
with three to choose from Holden sauce
right and my penis thinks that's not
really necessary if you are driving
through the countryside it should smell
of countryside and not like a city
apartment with home fragrances the
second generation is as spacious as the
first most adults can sit in the back
without suffering
[Music]
the plastic cover on the upper edge of
the bumper at the rear is another plus
point immittance ground clearance is 22
centimetres she says if you want to
venture off road the optional extra
advanced grip control will help you
it has hill assist descent control and
five driving modes for different
terrains but the 3008 has front-wheel
drive so it is not entirely suited for
cross-country
gelinda geike nuts the 3008 GT is fun
and it's sporty it should delight modern
city folk who want to cross over dressed
as an SUV
we are already curious about the changes
this chameleon of a car will adopt for
its third generation
[Music]